24 heures sur la lune présente spécial
proche orient israël palestine choix
impossible
le proche orient vit des heures
décisives que se passe-t-il en israël ou
le triomphe d'arafat à l'onu a semé la
colère
que se passe-t-il en syrie non se
prépare pour une cinquième guerre cette
émission spéciale que vous pourrez voir
aujourd'hui même à 14 heures est composé
des documents qui étaient destinés au
dernier numéro de notre magazine au
rendez vous des grands reporter magazine
qui n'a pu être diffusé en raison du
bouleversement des programmes
parmi ces documents se réaliser par deux
équipes de 24 heures sur la une qui
opérent l'une en syrie et l'autre du
côté israélien ont réussi à se
rencontrer dans le no man's land qui
sépare les deux adversaires
après ces reportages un débat opposera
un journaliste arabe et un journaliste
israélien
cette émission spéciale sera présentée
en ouverture de la une est à vous
aujourd'hui même à 14 heures